[Music]
this memo is really a spin on a not just
a set of particular documents but
broader classified information than that
this memo is important to the American
people understanding what is going on in
the Department of Justice and the
Federal Bureau of Investigation I will
tell you that it is full of false as
though it is a shoddy and poorly written
memo it's very significant want to
oversell it but I'm saying this is vital
it's essential for the public to see and
it's certainly important in the body of
evidence to be out there it's gonna get
review from all relevant stakeholders
that includes intelligence folks and
folks in a law-enforcement community
they'll be advising the president and
he'll make a decision at the appropriate
time
we've covered we've talked about it a
lot of people have talked about it we
think it's coming out tomorrow morning
actually a lot of talk today about edits
made before the White House saw it and a
back and forth on that the Intelligence
Committee committee putting out a
statement in the majority it's
increasingly strange attempt to thwart
publication of the memo the committee
minority is now complaining about minor
edits to the memo including grammatical
fixes and two edits requested by the FBI
and the minority themselves the vote to
release the memo was absolutely
procedurally sound in in accordance with
the house and committee rules to suggest
otherwise as a bizarre distraction from
the abuse is detailed in the memo which
in public will hopefully and soon be
able to read for themselves we think
that will happen again tomorrow morning
let's bring in our panel Steve Hays
editor in chief for the Weekly Standard
Mar liason national political
correspondent for National Public Radio
and Molly Hamming why senior editor at
The Federalist okay Steve where are we
on this and where it stands it seems the
story has now some of it gone too is the
memo going to be all that it's even
Republican lawmakers think it's going to
be well I'm not sure at this point that
it possibly can be because so much has
been made of them the build-up has been
so great having said that I think there
will be significant new information the
memo I mean I think that what we learned
about the behavior of certain law
enforcement senior federal law
enforcement officials will be troubling
to people
is it enough to change the debate in
Washington about Trump and Russia and
the FBI and all this I don't think it
probably is but I think we'll learn new
information it will trigger another
round of finger-pointing back and forth
but it'll be nice at least to understand
what the claims and counterclaims are in
a way that we haven't been as we've
debated this for the last couple of
weeks here is speaker Ryan on the whole
political distraction argument I think
they would love nothing more than to
play politics and change the subject
devyn nudists helped Shepherd through a
reauthorization of 702 which is the
foreign terrorist foreign surveillance
law so he's focusing on keeping our
country safe focus on national security
I think what they're trying to do is
just sidetrack us with some political
game was really interesting today
because he went on to say let me tell
you what this memo is and isn't the memo
is Congress doing oversight of the FBI
what it isn't is an attack on our
institutions it's not an attack on the
FBI the Department of Justice it's not
an attack on robert muller or his
investigation the fact that he even had
to say that shows you the kind of
unprecedented moment that we're at which
is you've got the president at war
basically feuding with his hand-picked
FBI director his hand-picked deputy
attorney general who both didn't want
this memo to come out they said it it's
omissions led to an inaccurate picture
and that's something we haven't ever
seen before
mullein yeah it's not surprising that
the FBI would be freaking out about this
memo coming out they have expressed a
lot of concern nobody likes to have
their dirty laundry aired and this
reportedly will air some of that dirty
laundry it's a little bit more
disconcerting how many other people have
sort of joined with them to keep
Americans from learning about these
abuses that are at the FBI and just
learning more information Adam Schiff
did a last-ditch effort to try and fight
this memo from being available to the
American people he of course fought the
subpoenas that led to the information
about this there is a general
obstruction there that we've seen from
Democrats on the committee also from the
FBI themselves they spent the entire
last year obstructing requests for
information so I think this is I think
it's wise to temper expectations it's
not going to be a huge deal at the same
time I think it's the beginning of a
long process of
out exactly what was going on at this
agency and learning more and just
bringing it to light so what do you make
of commis tweet I just put it up earlier
in the show all should appreciate the
FBI speaking up I wish more of our
leaders would but take heart American
history shows that in the long run
weasels and Liars never hold the field
so long as good people stand up not a
lot of schools or streets named for Joe
McCarthy and there will also not be a
lot of schools or streets named for
James Comey in all likelihood it's very
odd that he would make this reference to
McCarthy after Comey himself perpetuated
this Russia collusion theory privately
admitting to people in the White House
that there was no investigation of
Donald Trump but publicly intimating
that there was it's kind of interesting
to see former FBI director former CIA
director Brennan on Twitter kind of
tossing balls in to the public discourse
occasionally like this yeah well they're
well within their rights to do that you
know it's I think it's to a certain
extent informative at the in many ways
that I think our colleagues in the
mainstream media have shown an in
capability of imagining that people like
James Comey would be political people
like John Brennan would be political and
for those of us who reported on the
various episodes over the last eight
years from Benghazi to Guantanamo to the
Iran deal it's pretty clear that they
were capable of being political so I
think one of the things that will come
out of the release of this memos that
we'll see more politics in all
likelihood now
does that then invalidate the entire
investigation into Trump and Russia I
don't think it does there are many
outstanding questions that we don't have
answers to right now I mean if if the
FBI played games with FISA applications
does that somehow exculpate Donald Trump
jr. from his meeting at Trump Tower for
misleading people about it I mean
there's still an investigation to be had
even if it's the case that people do
that and Maura the New York Times has an
article saying among other things mr.
Carrillo who was a PR person is planning
to tell mr. Malla special counsel about
a previously undisclosed conference call
with mr. Trump and hope Hicks the White
House communications director
Corallo planned to tell investigators
that Miss Hicks said during the call
that emails written by Donald Trump jr.
before the Trump Tower meeting in which
the younger mr. Trump said he was eager
to receive political dirt about mrs.
Clinton from the Russians quote we'll
never get out that left mr. krolow with
concerns that Miss Hicks could be
contemplating obstructing justice hope
Hicks attorney has issued a statement as
most reporters know it's not my practice
to comment in response to questions from
the media but this warrants a response
she never said that and the idea that
hope Hicks ever suggested that emails or
other documents would be concealed or
destroyed is completely false the
zeroing in on the airforce one meeting
about the release the press release that
came out about the Trump but what's
interesting about that is first of all
those are four words we don't know what
the context was we don't know if she
said them she denies it or what the
purpose of that was the other thing is
this was a statement that was released
to the media this wasn't wasn't a
statement that he was giving to the FBI
but what I think is so interesting about
this whole debate is it wasn't that long
ago that Democrats were saying the FBI
was politically biased against Hillary
they were saying there were some FBI
agents who leaked to Rudy Giuliani put
pressure on James Comey to release the
information about the emails found on on
weiners laptop now we've got Republicans
doing this so maybe there's cabal's on
the left and the right in the FBI but
they're definitely in you know I'm not
seen right I mean I've went to the New
York Times Duran law Street Journal
story is about how mccabe was sitting on
anthony Weiner's the email found on
anthony Weiner's computer for weeks
maybe to get it past the election i
think people should think less about
whether this benefits hillary or
benefits Trump so much as we need to
have an FBI that can be trusted no
matter who is being investigated and
they need to follow procedures and not
be political and it can hurt and they
did hurt Hillary Clinton and they did
possibly hurt Donald Trump it's there's
no conflict videos